derère fin
derre le brling Jet Team est la seule
patrouille professionnelle privé à volé
sur les avions
réaction45 pour la première fois nous
avons mis les pieds ou les ailes en
terre africaine à l'invitation du Cap
Vert vol au Cap Vert cétait complètement
inédit çaésente toujours un par qu'on l'
jamais
fait on a rejoint ce lieu en suivant un
parcours qui avait entrepris
l'aéropostal dans les années 20 dans les
années
30 c'est une vraie émotion presque en
avoir les poils qui se dressent sur les
bras
[Musique]
quoi
le bretling Jet Team est une patrouille
de Volti imaginé créé mise en place par
botelin en 1981 qui vole sur des jets et
qui est donc la seule patrouille du
monde professionnelle privée à voler sur
des avions réaction c'est une équipe de
7 jet L39 Albatros queon essaie de faire
voler en formation serrée pour donner de
l'émotion et du spectacle à un
public après l'armistice de 1918 ils
sont quelques entrepreneurs à croire au
lendemain de l'aviation parmi eux Pierre
George latcoer un jeune industriel
visionnaire imagine la création d'une
ligne postale aérienne anticipant la
reprise qui va suivre la près-guerre dès
août 1918 il cherche à convaincre l'État
français de l'aider à mettre en œuvre la
liaison aérienne entre Paris et
buenoosire devant l'incrédulité des
politiques il fonde sa compagnie l'année
suivante avec le soutien du marquis bppo
de Massimi en rachetant des avions mis
au surplu militaire il décide d'avancer
pas à pas et de créer un premier tronçon
entre Toulouse et Casablanca après un
coup médiatique le mars 1919 les lignes
aériennes lateker voient officiellement
le jour le 1er septembre de cette même
année nous utilisons d'anciens avions
militaires qui étaient en en service
dans les forces de l'Est avant la chute
du mur de Berlin et puis ces avions se
trouvant déclassés nous avons eu
l'occasion et la chance de pouvoir les
acquérir pour faire évoluer cette
patrouille c'est un petit peu
l'équivalent de l'alpagette français un
avion facile à mettre en œuvre à opérer
à voler super avion initialement il y
avait des instruments des possibilités
d'emport d'armes que nous avons bien
entendu enlevé et nous avons ajouté du
matériel qui permet de voler dans les
nuages de faire ce qu'on appelle de
l'IFR d'utiliser les les voies aériennes
et de de voler par tout les temps grâce
à ces composants électroniques que nous
avons installés à
bord
ils ont retrouvé ou trouvver c'est comme
on veut un emploi une livrée beaucoup
plus
pacifique pour ces avions là c'est une
nouvelle vie pour nous aussi d'ailleurs
puisquon est tous pour la plupart
d'anciens pilotes militaires et on a
maintenant l'occasion de faire partager
juste notre passion et notre but
maintenant c'est ne plus de préparer des
gens à faire la guerre c'est de faire
rêver les
gens
alors cette patrouille elle évolue un
petit peu partout en Europe et et
presque dans le monde c'estàd qu'on sort
d'Europe de temps en temps mais pour la
première fois nous avons mis les pieds
ou les ailes en terre africaines à
l'invitation de l'organisme qui
aujourd'hui contrôle les avions qui
traversent l'Atlantique Sud le centre de
contrôle océanique du Cap Vert ça
représente toujours un défi parce qu'on
l' jamais
fait personne avant nous n'avait été sur
les îles du Cap Vert en tant que
patrouille acrobatique c'était un
challenge pour nous non pas dans le côté
difficulté technique mais ça reste une
destination lointaine ça peut paraître
paradoxal qu'un déplacement sur les îles
du Cap Vert représente une aventure à
une époque où les avions des compagnies
aérienne délivre des centaines et des
milliers de passagers presque
quotidiennement par exemple sur
l'aéroport de salle au Cap Vert avec un
A380 on peut aller au bout du monde tout
simplement par qu'il a été conçu pour ça
avec avec suffisamment de de carburant
et donc des réservoirs conséquents nos
avions non n'ont rien d'avion de ligne
intercontinentaux leur autonomie est
très limitée à peu près 1000 Km au
maximum avec les réservoirs
supplémentaires dès qu'on rencontre des
conditions atmosphériques difficiles et
bien il faut arriver à les les traverser
à 7 vent de sable risque d'orage dans
certains secteurs donc ça veut dire que
comme toute chose en aéronautique ça
nécessite de prendre des précautions
d'être rigoureux et c'est pas aussi
évident que ça ne le paraît
un pilote aime regarder une carte il
rêve il voyage en regarde dans une carte
c'est c'est le début du vol c'est
toujours super alléchant d' aller
toujours envie d'y aller mais après il y
a quand même toute la phase de
préparation déjà la question est-ce
qu'on peut y aller est-ce que les îes ne
sont pas trop éloignées du continent en
fonction de notre rayon d'action les
choix d'itinéraire sont fait en fonction
de notre autonomie limitée d'une part
ensuite de l'accessibilité des aéroports
qui peuvent nous accueillir qui doivent
être lorsqu'on transite d'un un pays à
un autre un aéroport international
ensuite rentrre des données économiques
qui sont le prix du carburant le prix
des taxes d'atterrissage et le mélange
de tous ces paramètres organis de trajet
les risques d'une d'un voyage comme
celui-là sont évidemment la panne la
panne moteur dans des régions
montagneuses dans des régions
désertiques régions maritimes les
embuches il faut les prévoir avant donc
je dirais que la plus grosse embuche ça
serait d'en oublier une d'oublier
quelque chose et se retrouver coincé
dans un coin parce qu'on a pas pensé à
tout sans forcément vouloir
exactement reproduire les le trajet de
l'aréropostale il s'est avéré que le
plus simple pour aller au Cap ver
c'était de passer quasiment par les
mêmes étapes on est parti à peu près une
semaine avant la date de la première
démonstration Guillaume m'avait précédé
sur les routes Guillaume connaissait les
trucs qui livrent les clés de l'Espagne
il me fallait être initié par Guillaum
quand j'entrais chez lui il sourit il
s'en fut au placard chercher le le
Porteau et les veres puis revint à moi
souriant toujours il répandait la
confiance comme une lampe répand la
lumière ce camarade qui devait plus tard
battre le record des traversées postales
de la Cordière des Andes et de celle de
l'Atlantique
Sud quelques années plus tôt ce soir-là
en manche de chemise les bras croisés
sous la lampe souriant du plus
bienfaisant des sourires il me dit
simplement les orages la brume la neige
quelque foois ça t'embêtera pense alors
à tous ceux qui ont connu ça avant toi
et dis-toi simplement ce que d'autres
ont réussi on peut toujours le
réussir cependant je déroulais mes
cartes et je lui demandais quand même de
revoir un peu avec moi le voyage et
penché sous la lampe appuyé à l'épaule
de l'ancien je retrouvais la paix du
[Musique]
collège on a posé des plans de vol la
veille on a les autorisations de survol
d'atterrissage on connait les
destinations le point bien entendu c'est
la météo toujours vérifier que à
l'arrivée et sur le trajet les
conditions soit acceptable pour faire
voler cet avion ensemble et pouvoir les
poser et puis on y vaçon faut y
aller la prière sensation du départ
sensation plisir parce que ça intervient
après la saison hivernale donc on est un
peu comme des chevaux qui sommes restés
à l'écurie assez longtemps on p
d'impatience d'aller s'étirer les
papates un peu dans les air et donc les
ailes en
[Musique]
l'occurrence a toujours envie de partir
d'ailleurs si on est un petit peu bloqué
au départ parce qu'il y a une mauvaise
météo ou des choses comme ça on est
toujours un petit peu embêté a un côté
aventure même si c'est une aventure bien
préparé
a apps
modve le faitêrealler dans pays sur
lesquel on jamais poser les roues un
petit côtéz
sympa on est pass un peu larign et suiv
la côte comme la LI l'épo en fait mais
beaucoup plus haut 10 15 FO plus
ha les pilotes de l'éropost quasiment
sur le même trait
au départ ils ont tenté de d'aller en
direct de montudran Toulouse montudran
vers Valence mais ils se sont hé donc au
pyéné au mauvais temps c'était des
avions qui volaient mal en altitude avec
une ascension pénible pour pouvoir avoir
une chance de passer les sommets il faut
être sûr en permanence ben déjà de pas
se retrouver dans les nuages pas uneam
avoir l'altitude de sécurité qui va bien
par rapport à l' hautur des montagnes
mais avec des instruments de VSV assez
rudimentaire pour
l'époque phénomènes aérologiques très
violents qui font que on peut ou ne plus
avancer ou descendre par la force des
choses ou tout simplement perdre toute
référence extérieure quand la météo est
mauvaise donc ils ont vite compris qu'il
valait mieux passer par la vallée
Carcassonne béisier et ensuite Perpignan
et suivre la côte en fait il vraiment il
restaient il restaient près de la côte
parce qu'ils avaient des moteurs
poussifs parce qu'ils avaient des
plafonds très limités à l'époque et
aussi parce qu'il fallait garder la vue
du sol pour
naviguer nous on n pas ce genre de
problème Paron monte quand même beaucoup
plus vite et beaucoup plus haut en
général on n pas forcément dans les
zones de forte turbulence avec des
grosses précipitations on est auudessus
des zone de givrage important donc c'est
pas trop un souci pour
[Musique]
N
pr PL de bol on va payer les taxes
d'issage a pas mal travail chacun un
petit peu son petit rôle de fourmis au
sein de l'équipe oness météo
sur
consult nous sommes à Valencia en
Espagne on est sur le parking on attend
que les soutiers espagnols finissent le
plein là à peu près 1500 l dans les
avions par avion quand les avions seront
ravitaillés on repartira vers Raba au
Maroc on a une grosse préparation
sachant qu'on n pas de d'avion de
liaison avec nous donc il y a il y a
énormément de pièces en fait à apporter
au maximum malgré la place qu'on qu'on a
on a plein de petites cachettes dans
l'avion le moindre espace dans l'avion
est utilisé pour stocker une petite
pièce de rechange une petite pompe
hdrolique par-ci connecteur par là un
boîtier électronique ailleurs jusque sur
les côté du siège dans la cabine on va
privilégier l'emport de pièces à
l'emport de Jean de chemise voilà on
emporte le stri nécessaire il faut
effectivement avoir des petits sacs de
voyage deè étape de la journée lorsque
les avions sont enfin prêts on
redécolle mon rassemblement on suit
toute la côte est de l'Espagne un survol
assez extraordinaire puisque dans le sud
de l'Espagne il y a des des des
montagnes relativement
[Musique]
importantes
et
Gibraltar je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
c'est toujours une émotion que de passer
l'éroit de Gibraltar je trouve que ce
rocher est tellement symbolique de de
beaucoup de choses et la côte africaine
paraît très près c'est assez étonnant de
de voir que on a un jet de pierre
pratiquement et en quelques minutes de
vol on quitte l'Europe pour se retrouver
en
Afrique le Maroc est un pays fantastique
magnifique en fait on s'attend à voir du
sable un paysage jaune des couleurs
jaunes mais qui qui est très vert qui
est très verdoyant
[Musique]
quoi
c'est le début de l'aventure on est
sorti de l'Europe on a les senteurs les
gens les voix les bruits sont différents
voilà c'est
parti en reliant Toulouse à Barcelone le
jour de Noël 1918 Pierre-George latcoer
réussit à éveiller l'intérêt des hommes
politiques pour son projet fou de lignes
aériennes postales le général lioté
résident général au Maroc est
particulièrement enthousiaste à l'idée
de voir le protectorat se rapprocher de
la France afin de prouver la viabilité
de son idée la Teker décide de se rendre
sans tarder à rabat avec un Salmson la
première tentative en février 1919 est
un échec la seconde sera la bonne après
plus de 28 heures de voyage le 9 mars
1919 Pierre George latcoer est accueilli
en triomphe par lyoté symboliquement il
offre général un exemplaire du journal
Le Temps daté du 7 mars et à sa femme un
bouquet de violette emblème de la ville
de
Toulouse
[Musique]
bon
bonneur
[Musique]
pour
s while
[Musique]
he
un vol assez fantastique on a eu la
chance de voir l'Atlas montagne mythique
avec quelques sommet en neigé c'est
toujours pe paradoxal de voir de la
neige dans ces pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chauds et nous étions sur sensiblement
la même route que ce que devait utiliser
la ligne car eux-mêmes devait contourner
cette chaîne de montagne et pour des
facilités de navigation le plus souvent
suivre le trait de côte jusqu'à leur
destination
suivante et on est arrivé avec un temps
un peu brumeux certainement B de
[Applaudissements]
sable
le sable peut-être un problème parce que
ça rentre partout on essaie d'enlever le
maximum de graisse qui a F mesure des
vols est ressorti légèrement et qui du
coup en gros accumule toutes ces ces
grains de sable ou ce sel qui pourrait y
avoir les joints notamment tout ce qui
est caoutchou souffre énormément et les
réacteurs également donc il y a des des
consignes on doit bien rincer nettoyer
les avions lorsqu'on vole dans le
sable
[Musique]
là on commence à trouver la chaleur à
Agadir et le passage du sud de l'atlace
nous amène vraiment dans le début du
vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Sud les alentours d'Agadir sont de plus
en plus équipés de serre qui nous
ravitaille toute l'année en fraise en
haricot vert et choses de ce genre-là
donc donc c'est de moins en moins
désertique immédiatement autour d'Agadir
mais dès qu'on quitte Agadir au sud là
ça devient vraiment
[Musique]
désertique
cap au Sud sur Darla alors là ça devient
très très évocateur de tous ces récits
de l'Aéropostale avec les avions qui
longe la côte qui en cas de pas de
moteur se pose sur la
plage le trajet côtier que l'on a pris
exactement le même que à l'époque 90 ans
en arrière il suivit la côte environ 1
2000 pieds 500 600 m
d'altitude et souvent vers le sud Maroc
et la Mauritanie il y a des espèces de
brumes de mer de stratus qui viennent de
la mer et qui recouvrent complètement la
côte donc il volit au-dessus et là il
perdit le contact visuel de la côte il
reparter un petit peu dans le désert
pour retrouver le contact visuel du sol
enfin c'était vraiment très difficile de
naviguer pour eux un petit moment
d'émotion c'est que sous quelques nuages
se trouve l'escale mythique de
l'Aéropostale
on est passé juste à côté de la Yun et
juste à côté de la Yun il y a tarfay qui
est l'ancien capjubi ou monsieur de
saintexupéri a été chef d'escale pendant
un certain
temps capjubi c'est un cap comme son nom
l'indique qui était lui aussi un ancien
comptoir mi espagnol mi français
apparemment céit un endroit magique on n
pas pu s'y poser parce que ça
correspondait pas à notre
notre plan de vol on l'a vu de loin mais
c'est un nom qui est beau rien que rien
qu'à l'entendre comme vill cisner
d'ailleurs ce sont des c'est des noms
qui font rêver parce non qui sont reliés
à ces aventures
[Musique]
là on voit on l'identifie même à 7000 m
d'altitude se dire que quelque part ces
nuages sont peut-être les nuages sur
lequels un petit prince essayit pour
peindre la
[Musique]
terre là on est dans le vif du sujet le
sable à gauche au Cap Sud et et la mer à
droite et là vraiment on est sur les
traces de l'Aéropostale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
[Musique]
ce qui est beau c'est d'avoir cette
différence de de lumière entre la droite
et la gauche de l'avion et puis et puis
d'arriver à darala sur cette espèce de
de péninsule
Darla l'ancien villa sisneros où se
posait
[Musique]
l'éropostal on se pose à Darla c'est un
terrain qui un peu plus isolé c'est une
ancienne ville de garnison enfin c'est
toujours un peu une ville de garnison de
l'époque troublé du Sahara
espagnol là le le dépaissement est
total cette ville de confin du désert où
où ça sent le sable
elle s'appelait villa cisnaros à
l'époque C à la fois un comptoir et un
fort espagnol d'où la consonance
[Musique]
hispanique à l'époque les avion se posé
sur le sable directement et au plus près
d'ffort pour pouvoir être abrité abrité
à la fois l'avion mais au moins
l'équipage le courrier qui était mis à
l'abri pendant la nuit et qui était
rechargé le lendemain matin quand on lit
saintugus Péry on lit le petit prince et
on se dit ben oui c'est je comprends ce
qu'il a pu ressentir là on ne fait que
le survoler mais on a cette on se
représente parfaitement ce qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut ressentir dans dans un champ
de Dune dans dans le
silence j'ai beaucoup aimé le Sahara
j'ai passé des nuits en dissidence je me
suis réveillé dans cette étendue blonde
où le vent a marqué sa houle comme sur
la mer
j'y ai attendu des secours en dormant
sous mon aile mais ce n'était point
comparable nous marchons en versant des
collines courbes le sol est composé de
sable entièrement recouvert d'une seule
couche de caillou brillant et noir on
dirait des écailles de métal et tous les
dôme qui nous entourent brille comme des
armures nous sommes tombés dans un monde
minéral nous sommes enfermés dans un
paysage de
fer on repart donc le lendemain et le
but était de faire deux étapes pour
arriver directement au Cap ver le
lendemain donc Darla direction noadiibou
[Musique]
Mauritanie
de passer de la frontière mauritanienne
on est descendu un petit
[Musique]
peutit ça faisait vraiment plaisir à
tout le monde donc jacquestient
l'autorisation du contrôleur et nous
descendons en basse
altitude bien basse sur le
[Musique]
désert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on arrive là les choses se sont un peu
compliquées
[Musique]
on s'est retrouvé avec des gens
extrêmement
sympathiques aimables mais armé et on se
demande si ça ne va pas dégénérer en
fait vous êes CIV ou
militaire les avions sont
armés
capitaine êes
militaire voulez absolument qu'on soit
militaire non on n pas de militaire mais
oui mais dans l'armée vous êtes de quel
grade donc c'était un petit peu
obsessionnel et un peu
pénible on était pas préparé à
ça on avait fait toutes les demandes
officielles de manière à éviter
justement ce genre de problème on a
discuté il a fallu s'expliquer montrer
les papiers et la tente
ça aussi c'est l'Afrique il faut savoir
être patient ils ont pris le temps de
vérifier qui nous étions ça nous a
permis encore une fois de de se dire que
tout n'était pas gagné qu'il fallait
savoir rester humble que c'était chez
eux et que à partir de là il fallait
attendre c'est une philosophie africaine
de dire non monsieur vous vous êtes
pressé moi
non
on se remet à la place des des gens qui
faisaient ces étapes là qui dormaient
sous détente qui subissaient les
tempêtes de sable et qui au petit matin
se levaient ou avaient dormi s sous
leurs avions remettaient leurs avions en
route et repartaient du désert cette
fois en la mission les amenait à prendre
des risques très importants dans des
contrées
hostiles très peu peuplé il y avait des
résou il y avait des bandes organisées
qui étaient souveraines à l'époque dans
ces régions c'était leur désert et il
leur arrivait quand les pilotes se
posaient en plein désert de les
kidnapper les rendre la plupart du temps
mais moyen en moyen en rançon donc il y
avait il y avait du
danger quelques camarades dont mermose
Guillaumet fondèrent la ligne française
de Casablanca à Dakar à travers le
Sahara insoumis les moteurs d'alors ne
résiste en guerre une panne livra
mermose au morts ils hésitèrent à le
massacrer le gardèrent 15 jours
prisonniers puis le revendirent et
mermos reprit ses courriers au-udessus
des mêmes
[Musique]
territoires c'était la vision de Diora
qui n'admettait pas que le courrier
puisse prendre du retard pour des
raisons
contestables ces avions ont Boué de
pacifique dans leur emploi il reste des
avions d'apparence militaire on avait
les réservoirs supplémentaires qui lors
qu'on vole peuvent ressembler
éventuellement à des
bombes le petit problème c'est qu'on a
survolé les casmates des gardes
frontaliers des militaires mauritaniens
il n'étaient pas prévenus de de notre
arrivée il y a eu un petit kiproco entre
l'aviation civile et les les militaires
mauritaniens les gardes frontaliers ont
ont eu l'impression que cet avion
attaqua leur pays ils étaient persuadés
qu'en fait on venait faire un coup
d'état donc on peut comprendre que les
militaires soi ça va un petit peu
réveiller la défense aérienne du
coin on est resté coincé sur le terrain
de noibou pendant une bonne partie de la
journée sans être certain de pouvoir
repartir le soir en direction du
caber j'étais agacé parce que dans un
but de sécurité on avait demandé à nos
camarades de l'aéronaval de bien vouloir
être en alerte renforcé avec le Breg
Atlantique qui est stationné à Dakar
pour que si jamais on tombe à l'eau le
temps de recherche maximum avant la nuit
nous permette d'être être localisé voir
récupéré donc plus le temps avance dans
la journée et plus les marges de
sécurité qu'on a pris et ces
dispositions qu'on a pris en matière de
sécurité ça me nuise c'est ça qui me
préoccupe tout au long de la
journée on avait prévu de redécoller en
début d'après-midi de manière à arriver
au moins 3 à 4 heur avant le coucher de
soleil et là on est arrivé au coucher de
soleil
là on quitte les traces de la ligne qui
elle poursuivait visneros pour Étienne
ensite Dakar donc là nous on
quitteostale pour aller aux î du Cap
Vert là c'est 1h45 de survol
maritime
[Musique]
en général les gens dans l'aviation de
chasse ou dans dans dans le métier qu'on
fait avec un monomoteur n'aiment pas
trop survoler la mer on est au-dessus de
l'eau alors bon c'est pas grave parce
que l'avion le sait pas donc il y a
aucune raison qui tombe plus en panne là
qu'ailleurs effectivement il y a
beaucoup moins de piste d'atterrissage
sur l'eau que que sur le continent
quoi quand tu es en plein milieu de la
patouille comme ça tu as tendance à bien
surveiller tes éléments de l'avion on a
une oreille différente on écoute son
avion d'une manière plus attentive faut
rester concentrer pour suivre la
navigation euh gérer le carburant euh
voilà pour nous perdre un moteur
au-dessus de l'Atlantique c'est
l'assurance de finir dans un Cano avant
de le retrouver ce Canau il va se passer
du
temps il est bien évident que le temps
de survie il est beaucoup plus faible
euh au milieu de l'Atlantique que que
dans le désert ou sur une plage au bord
de la mer quoi l'avion lui a une balise
et dans le C il y a également encore une
balise portable donc il y a y a des
moyens on n pas comme à l'époque des
pionniers où il
partait puis voilà quoi ils en avaient
des grosses les gars
c'est à l'époque la distance la plus
courte pour traverser le l'Atlantique
Sud c'est de Saint-Louis du Sénégal
jusqu'à natal alors tout au début ça
faisait encore en bateau les avions
amené le courrier à Saint-Louis qui
partait ensuite vers le Brésil et
ensuite les hydravions ont réussi à
poursuivre cette route
[Musique]
pour éviter au courrier de traverser
l'Atlantique pour aller en Amérique du
Sud par aviso donc très très long les
avisau les bateaux Dora s'est reposé
encore une fois sur mermaau qui est un
fonceur qui est un bâtisseur et d'autres
faut pas oublier les
[Musique]
autres là c'était dans les années 30 les
avions ét un peu plus modernes ils
étaient multimoteur ils avaient des
moyens de navigation et il volent en
équipage il fallait voler très bas dans
les turbulences dans les les nuages dans
le givrage et les moyens navigation
n'étaient pas terrible et notamment dans
cette zone de l'Atlantique il y avait ce
qu'on appelait le poteau noir
c'est-à-dire une zone de la la
convergence intertropicale qui qui qui
crée des orages qui sont extrêmement
puissants et chaque fois ce passage qui
se souvent d'ailleurs était à quelques
mètres au-dessus des des flots pour
garder la visibilité de la mer et
continuer à progresser c'était une vraie
é
preuve c'est là également sur le fameux
la Croix du Sud qu'il a disparu en en
plein milieu de l'océan très
probablement à la suite d'une d'une P
d'une rupture d'un arbre
d'hélice ainsi mermose avait défriché
les sables la montagne la nuit et la mer
il avait sombré plus d'une fois dans les
sables la montagne la nuit et la mer et
quand il était revenu ça avait toujours
été pour repartir enfin après 12 années
de travail comme il survelait une fois
de plus l'Atlantique Sud il signala par
un bref message qu'il coupait le moteur
arrière
droit puis le silence se fit
c'est de l'eau c'est de l'eau c'est de
l'eau et et même dans le GPS c'est tout
bleu et on est bien content de voir un
petit bout de terre qui apparaît au bout
de au bout de 2h 2h20 au bout du cockpit
là-bas l'impression d'être comme dans un
bateau avec le galao qui crie terre
terre
terre on Arve on fera 360 en Avenger et
on sortira pour ensuite refaire un L
pour venir dans l'AX passer en grande
flèche et break gauche et je vous
propose de venir en place et bien on se
rapproche on est en place quent en place
presque
on a l'impression d'être au bout du
monde l'accueil est
[Musique]
extraordinaire nous avons découvert des
gens extrm chaleureux extrêmement
charmant qui qui cherchait tout ce qu'il
pouvait faire pour pour nous faire
plaisir et là quand on a mis les pieds
sur leur terre on s'est dit on va passer
un super séjour et ça va être super
[Musique]
agréable ça va aussi encore plus nous
motiver bien évidemment pour un are tour
essayer de leur faire plaisir et de leur
donner un beau spectacle et de répondre
à leurs
attent le lendemain de l'arrivée pour
les mécaniciens c'est une journée de
remise en œuvre des avions le piège est
justement de se relâcher on va se
relâcher un peu et en sachant que qu'on
n pas là pour c'est pas des vacances
nous c'est rencontre des autorités et
les organisateurs pour un petit peu
planifier les vols reconnaître les sites
les axes de vol le timing le calendrier
donc une journée de préparation pour la
petite tournée qu'on va effectuer les
jours suivants le programme au Cap Vert
était trois démonstrations prévues sur
trois îles différentes pour célébrer les
25 ans d'existence de la Direction de
l'Aviation Civile capverdienne c'était
un cadeau offert à sa population bon
messieurs on se réveille on est plus en
[Musique]
vacances
dé
[Musique]
inqu sécurité
alors le petit point c'est qu'on est
posé sur l'Î deente prière démonstration
3 He avec une démonstration prévue à
Mo c'est un petit peu venteux bien
évidemment on va prendre des marches
pour assurer le spectacle mais surtout
assurer la sécurité je pense qu'on va
travailler un petit peu la première
chose c'est d'arriver à mettre du
pétrole dans l'avion ce qui est pas
évident puisque il y a un point de
refing fix et on a pas été prévenu donc
on s'est pas garé en fonction ce qui
veut dire que nous manutentionnons ce
qui ça va nous permettre de faire un
petit peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'exercice qu'on arrive comme ça pour la
première fois sur un site où aucune
démonstration n'a eu lieu où les les
gens sont vraiment profanes totalement
on se demande quelle sera la la réaction
et on a vraiment envie de de séduire ces
gens pour moi c'est doublement marquant
parce que c'est ma première
démonstration publique donc je vais dire
je cumule et puis la démonstration
commence et une fois que
le que les chevaux soi lâchés c'est
parti on est dedans et ça se passe très
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on termine par le final et là on dit ben
voilà c'est fait
non c'est un peu dur ce vent nous a fait
bien souffrir et transpirer parce que
les les avions faisaient des bons de 2 à
3 m les uns entre les autres c'était pas
pas simple cé gauch
[Musique]
confir c'est toujours la magie de
d'abord la magie de
l'entraînement de la confiance en soi
qu'on a acquis pendant l'entraînement on
est pris dans le dans le côté 100 %
professionnel de de la place qu'on doit
tenir de l'anticipation qu'on doit avoir
on en oublie que c'est la première on
oublie qu'il y a du vent oublie du
[Musique]
public demain on va faire santam maria à
salle que du bonheur le long de la plage
dans la foulée on fait Praya une île qui
n'est pas sous le
vent terrain
donc viement
demain
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain on va moins loin on décole
de salle pour faire une démonstration
sur la plage de Santa Maria qui est
juste à
côté d'abord l'endroit est plus facile
c'est plat il y a autant
[Musique]
monde
ça
[Musique]
te pour ce qui me concerne l' gauche sur
Jacques mais en vision périphérique
toujours des couleurs des des paysages
des des flash des images les bateaux les
points des bateaux sur l'eau quand on
est sur leau t ces petit points blancs
et ce festival de cle
merille c'est magique c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
superbe
trè démonstration la dernière cette fois
on va sur
l'île principale en l' capitale en tout
cas donc à
pr le tret également survolé d'autes
extraordinaire un petit archipel avec
une
flopé tout différent certaines sont
extrêmement vert d'autres sont
complètement ras
désertes
[Musique]
on se pose là-bas et là il y a encore
plus de
[Musique]
monde la démonstration c'est sur
l'aéroport donc c'est un peu moins des
paysans pour pour nous on travaille par
rapport à une piste c'est vraiment ce à
quoi on est entraîné en France ou en
Europe mais il y a du monde
[Musique]
partout
W me up wake me up wake up W me
up and save
[Musique]
me from
nothing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
all les voler au Cap Vert c'était
complètement inédit jamais au Cap Vert
il n'y a eu de mitinien jamais au Cap
Vert les Capverdiens n'ont vu évoluer
des avions en
en formation en faisant de l'acrobatie
avec des fumigènes ENF jamais un
spectacle de ce type si nous nous
essayons de communiquer une émotion et
si nous avons réussi en retour nous
recevrons aussi une forme
[Musique]
d'émotion et ce qui nous est témoigné
dans ce cas est extrêmement chaleureux
extrêmement agréable à
vivre
on rentre à salle le vol de retour est
très beau parce que c'est le coucher de
soleil mais la fête est finie le côté
spectacle se
[Musique]
referme
na
[Musique]
solidting
et puis ben de nouveau on va consulter
la
météo voir comment comment se rendre
jusqu'à Dijon de
nouveau un peu triste de
partir il y a un moment particulier
c'est que les enfants les écoles
viennent nous dire au revoir et on a
tout un groupe d'enfants qui viennent
avec des
fleurs petits enfants qui avaient je
sais pas entre 3 5 ans je pense il sont
tous plus mignons les uns que les
autres tous les enfants avec les
bouquets de fleur c'est c'est
super pour un aviateur c'est difficile
de recevoir des fleurs parce que on n
pas vraiment de vas pour les mettre dans
notre avion
mais on est tellement touché par par ce
geste par cette gentillesse par leur
expression que on se dit mais de quoi on
a l'air si on laisse ces fleurs
[Musique]
ici on quit des
amis
[Musique]
et ben ces fleurs on les a mis dans un
vas particulier qui est entre les deux
pilotes elles ont fait le voyage retour
comme comme un symbole justement de cet
accueil et et de cette
[Musique]
gentillesse
le retour s'est passé selon les mêmes
itinéraires avec la même météo les mêmes
paysages le même bonheur à regarder le
même plaisir les mêmes émotions la même
aventure en fait mais en sens inverse ça
reste quand même une aventure il faut
bien le
dire c'est une vraie émotion comme ces
parcours de vie qu'on fait avec un
groupe le fait d'emmener une équipe
aussi loin est quelque chose qui est
unique pour ce qui concerne une équipe
civile le fait de le faire aussi sans
une assistance et un soutien technique
important est une performance en soi et
quand on revient ça donne le sentiment
de maîtriser son domaine ça enrichit ça
fortifie tout
simplement c'est un accomplissement un
accomplissement dans le métier de pilot
[Musique]
présentateur je pense que les gens qui
amenai le courrier loin av ce même
sentiment d'accomplissement de leur
métier ils ont relié trous Montauran à
Santiago du Chili je sais pas si vous
imaginez le parcours l'histoire de
l'Aéropostale est une partie extrêmement
significative du développement de cette
aviation moi 90 ans après dans Mo 39
avec mon équipe ben je ressens beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion énormément
d'émotion presque en avoir les poils qui
se dressent sur les bras quoi ce sont
les mêmes molécules d'air qui ont porté
les brget 14 de l'Aéropostale et qui
portent aujourd'hui Noël
[Musique]
on a vécu des des des belles choses
ensemble on a fait des des des
rencontres ensemble et il y a lien le
lien s'est resserré avant tout des
histoires d'homme avant tout toute façon
sans les hommes il se passe
[Musique]
rien le dernier vol est très très long
ça sent l'écurie comme on
[Musique]
dit
on a du mal à redescendre sur Terre on a
du mal à quitter la cabine de son avion
on a du mal àc sur Terre à retourner
vers les autres vers les
[Musique]
hommes à la maison après un périple
comme ça on a envie de raconter puis
d'un autre côté on s'aperçoit très vite
de la futilité des mots il est
extrêmement difficile de de faire
partager la beauté des sites qu'on a pu
survoler quelquefois l'angoisse de ce
qu'on a pu vivre l'émotion aussi de ce
qu'on a pu
ressentir parce que dans ça il y a
beaucoup de
[Musique]
choses un pilote a besoin de partir
besoin de revenir aussi c'est l'éternel
problème le ciel est vaste et on a on a
toujours l'impression de ne pas avoir
tout vu un pilote a toujours besoin de
partir pour mieux revenir évidemment
mais pour mieux repartir
[Musique]
après
ça c'est pour moi le plus beau et le
plus triste paysage du
monde c'est ici que le Petit Prince est
apparu sur terre puis
disparu regardez attentivement ce
paysage afin d'être sûr de le
reconnaître si vous voyagez un jour en
Afrique dans le désert et s'il vous
arrive de passer par là je vous en
supplie ne vous pressez pas attendez un
peu juste sous
l'étoile si alors un enfant vient à vous
s'il rit s'il a des cheveux d'or s'il ne
répond pas quand on l'interroge vous
devinerez bien qui il
est alors soyez gentil ne me laissez pas
tellement triste écrivez-moi vite qu'il
est
revenu on a cherché le petit prince on
l'a pas trouvé mais on le cherche
toujours en fait je le cherche toujours
je le cherche tout le
temps
[Musique]
très
légè renverse à
droite
[Musique]
and for all we us to
know you
all sleep
my as the day brows
down hear you say golden
[Musique]
h
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]